coming off the heels of the New
Hampshire primary Bernie Sanders and
Hillary Clinton took to the stage in
Milwaukee to do whatever they could to
attract the attention of South Carolina
primary voters didn't watch it here's
what happened in 90 seconds everything
started out fine with boring opening
statements and Clinton trying to remind
young women who haven't been supportive
of her lately that they could vote for
her too you know women are empowered to
make their own choices even if that
choice is not to vote for me then
Sanders talked Terriers off about
factory jobs now no one thinks the
working in the factory is the greatest
job in the world
but you know what you could make a
middle-class wage but this dude
advocates so hard for a minimum wage
increase to $15 an hour
quick economics lesson when you raise
the minimum wage to 15 bucks employers
just hire less people meaning those
factory jobs would likely feel the burn
in the end that being said the pair of
glasses was spot on when he called out
Republican candidates for wanting to cut
back government on fiscal issues but not
on social issues when it comes to a
woman having to make a very personal
choice in that case my Republican
colleagues love picked up a bit and then
Sanders went after Clinton's hawkish
foreign policy friends she talked about
getting the approval or the support of
Henry Kissinger journalists have asked
who you do listen to on foreign policy
and we have yet to know who that is
in fact Sanders went after her pretty
hard on foreign policy with Secretary
Clinton I disagree is the area of regime
change I do not believe a vote in 2002
is a plan to defeat Isis in 2016 but
there was this is it fair for Americans
no but it is absolutely fair and
necessary for Americans to vet both of
our proposals all right let's do that
see both of these cute little donkeys
want to expand government by the same
amount 100 billion dollars a year
hundred billion a year but don't worry
America it's hateful hateful paid for oh
Jesus that's never gonna work out and
that's about all we got from the
democratic debate